let's start with the end of the world
why don't we get it over with and move
on to more interesting things
those first two sentences introduce the
fact that
the end of the world is happening which
i think of as a really important
exciting
incident
you aren't stuck in the past when you're
writing fantasy
you aren't stuck in space when you're
writing science fiction
a lot of the things that we
traditionally think of as science
fiction
are actually fantasy for example star
wars
what's the force you can call it magic
it's space magic
in this master class we'll talk about
how to develop characters that are
interesting
people are three-dimensional people are
contradictory i'll be using my own
techniques derived from psychology and
my own background as a psychologist
we're going to actually start going
through an exercise where we build a
world from the planet level on down to
the people
we will talk about how to become a
professional writer if you work
and hone your craft you will eventually
break in
when i was small i would go to the
library and i would ask the librarians
to recommend science fiction books
they would recommend the big well-known
names
the problem with this is as a young
black girl
reading a bunch of novels written by a
bunch of middle-aged white dudes
there wasn't a whole lot in those
stories that was speaking to me
if you like me are a marginalized writer
you're going to encounter some bigotry
there are people out there who need your
example
who need you to go forth and fight that
battle so they won't have to fight as
hard
and it's worth it you help to change the
profession
by your existence i'm nk jemisin
and this is my master class
[Music]
you